in the lobby of Ramsey solutions it's
sibling day for debt-free screams the
third sibling in a row to do their
debt-free scream three hours in a row
Rebecca from Raleigh North Carolina hi
Rebecca how are you hi Dave I'm better
than I deserve
oh well good to have you so we had your
brother on and his wife last hour your
sister on the hour before and she's
doing work in China and you guys all
waited for her to come back from China
so you could do this all at the same
time yeah very cool and you are here for
your debt free scream mm-hmm how much
have you paid off one hundred and thirty
thousand dollars yo as much as the other
two put together yes
you killed it how long did this take you
five years five years Wow
and what was your income range during
that time I started at 42,000 and went
up to 90 good for you what do you do for
a living
the shock value answer is that I make
drugs okay the real answer is I work on
the production floor for a
pharmaceutical company very cool I love
it that's a great answer okay she's into
drugs that's good I love it so what kind
of debt was the hundred 110 was student
loans eighteen was my car and about one
thousand was just finishing off the
credit cards so what's your degree in I
actually have two I have a Bachelors of
Science and Chemical Engineering and a
Bachelor of Arts in religious studies
okay switch of course the first degree
is what put you on the drug floor yes
yeah gotcha
okay very cool and make it 90 K how old
are you I am I'll be 28 in August good
for you
very cool so five years ago who started
all of this um I think originally my mom
had gotten the CDs and even while I was
in college I saw how much money I was
racking up and just wanted to stay on
top of it as soon as I got out and
graduated so you did never feel
completely defeated like you would never
get out of debt you're just stuck or no
I never had that feeling I just knew
that it was the path I had chosen and I
would get out of it you just had to
clean up the mess yes yeah
cool all three of you have had this this
sense of destiny in your voice your
parents have done a good job all three
of you none of you are scared of
anything no you can attack anything and
get it if you need to I you're
impressive young people very cool very
cool very well done
all right so five years ago you're just
out of school when you're 23 and you're
going this is a mess but it's mine and
I'm gonna clean it up 130,000 bucks
including an $18,000 car yeah yeah and
so what happened tell me how you decided
mom got the CDs and then what happened
while I was in college I was keeping an
eye on how much I was taking out how
much interest was being accrued I tried
to keep the interest payments made so
that it wouldn't grow even more while I
was in school and then I started a debt
snowball to see how long it would take
me to pay it off and with the minimum
payments it was going to take years but
as soon as I graduated originally I
lived in a house with a couple of
roommates so that my rent was low and I
put every penny I had towards my debt I
did also take a part-time job delivering
pizzas for six months yeah
well that really taught me was that my
budget wasn't tight enough yet oh
because I was making that extra money
and it still wasn't helping my debt as
much as I thought it would no okay so
how did your income go up so
dramatically and me a double yes a lot
of overtime and I work night shift so
there's the shift differential oh very
cool okay which gives you a really large
shovel to knock this out because it's a
single person you can just draw back and
hit it yeah that's very good very cool
so what do you tell people there's
twenty eight year-olds out there
listening with a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars in student loan debt
they've been told by the news media and
the political culture that they can't do
it the government is going to have to
forgive their debts that can't be done
and yet you've gone and done this very
impressively I might add so what do you
tell that person how do you get out of
debt I guess the biggest thing is is you
need to take ownership for your mess if
you were old enough to make the decision
to go that far into debt then you're old
enough to take a responsibility and
clean it up you could be President Wow
excellent very well done good job
Rebecca so what are the keys to getting
out of debt definitely have an
accountability partner as a single
person it's so hard to make yourself do
things you're the one called your sister
a fruit loop I did she said last hour
she said in the first hour that she said
my sister just hit me that was a brother
on earlier so you're the sister that
called the other one a fruit loop that
was the accountability up yeah don't be
a fruit loop yeah exactly we were each
other's accountability partners it got a
little bit harder when she left the
country but you know Skype is an amazing
thing yeah to then still be able to talk
to each other and have that
accountability I know one of the really
hard things was my company matches 200%
of the first 3% you put in your 401k
that is hard and that was so hard not to
participate in while I was doing this
absolutely
well you've got plenty of time and you
make a lot of money and you don't have
any debt so whatever you missed out on
there you're gonna be in great shape
yeah so now who's the oldest Elizabeth
she's your sister's on earlier yes and
you're the little sister calling your
older sister of the fruit loop don't do
that don't be a fruit loop that's
hilarious and originally this was just
supposed to be her and I but you know
brothers have to crash the party well
that's the way that is yeah that's very
cool I love it well congratulations to
all of you very well done I'm very proud
of you know your parents are here
they're very proud of all of you
excellent excellent job all right
Rebecca Raleigh North Carolina 130,000
dollars paid off in five years making 42
to 90 our number one piece of advice own
it it's your mess count it down let's
hear a debt free scream today by ice
so I guess we got German in this time
okay
Chinese in the first hour it's perfect I
love it very well done very well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and say you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind